we're hearing new details this morning
about the family controversy surrounding
the death of legendary broadcaster Casey
Kasem the radio icon died more than four
years ago it led to a very bitter
dispute over his final resting place and
as the state estimated to be between 80
and 100 million dollars his three adult
children filed a wrongful death suit
against his second wife Jean Kasem she
later filed a countersuit both parties
reported claims of cruelty and neglect
Peter Van Zandt spoke to kayson's wife
and his daughters for next weekend's 48
hours this is Casey Kasem in Hollywood
and American top 40 in number from his
American top 40 countdown
[Music]
scooby-doo's pal shaggy everyone knew
that voice Jeannie Thompson his second
wife and a star of the hit TV show
cheers grew up listening to him I heard
this DJ come on and I went oh my god who
is this guy
Casey also had three kids from his first
marriage Carrie Mike and Julie but they
would have a strained relationship with
their new stepmom after more than 30
years of marriage Casey was diagnosed
with a debilitating parkinson's-like
disease
it was then his children say Jeannie cut
off their access to him starting in 2012
is when I felt that the isolation began
Jeannie says his children began a
campaign of harassment
we have been stalked tracked bullied the
family feud escalated when Kerry says
Jeannie put Casey's health at risk by
taking him out of a rehab facility Jean
Kasem pulled my dad out at 2:30 in the
morning out of a convalescent center
unhooked his g-tube unhooked his IV in
20-14 Kasem's family discovered that
gene had moved Casey to Washington state
armed with a court order to hospitalized
their dad this bizarre showdown occurred
between Carey and Jeannie
what person in their right mind throws
frozen meat at you
screaming biblical verses in June 2014
Casey Kasem died the family battle went
nuclear gene killed my father
when you say killed do you mean murder
what she did led to his death they
chemically restrained him they removed
his hydration his nutrition each side
has sued blaming the other for Casey's
death and there's even been drama during
depositions the case is scheduled for
next year a court may decide who gets
Casey's fortune I'm not going to quit
I'm the daughter of a marine and what
they did was wrong if someone killed
your father wouldn't you want justice
take the money take it all I want her in
jail boy that is not very very ugly I
remember when that story first broke and
I remember the meat throwing incident
there's still many questions but it's
interesting on Saturday's report
everybody will see for the first time
where Casey Kasem is buried remember for
a long time that was a big mystery that
will be revealed on Saturday I mean I
remember I listen to it's not that way
your feet on the ground and keep
reaching for the stars I love a
soundtrack literally of everybody's
growing up yeah I love that show and
like them too a lot you can watch
Peter's full report the mysterious death
of Casey Kasem Saturday night on 48
hours at airs at 10:00 9:00 central
right here on CBS